Alice was beginning to get very tired of
sitting by her sister on the bank and of
having nothing to do once or twice she
had peeped into the book her sister was
reading but it seemed very boring and
what is the use of a book thought Alice
without a little bit of magic
so she was imagining in her own mind a
world that was a little stranger and
more curious when suddenly a white
rabbit with pink eyes ran close by her
he took a watch out of his waistcoat
pocket and uttered with burning
curiosity Alice ran after him just in
time to see him pop down a large
rabbit-hole under the hedge down went
Alice after him never once considering
how in the world she was to get out
again the rabbit hole was so deep Alice
had time to look around and wonder if
there was a bottom and if she would ever
stop falling if the walls of the well
were infinitely high she would never get
out she could not jump over an
infinitely tall wall without infinite
energy down down down Alice began to
think about her cat Schroedinger back in
the garden in hopes that her family
would remember her saucer of milk at
tea-time
luckily Schrodinger was a smart cat and
actually had a map of the rabbit hole
his map showed the chance of finding
Alice at any given spot marked X he
wanted to figure out if there was any
chance for Alice to get outside of the
well to get over the wall of the well
Alice would need enough energy to jump
over it let's call that energy V right
now she has energy e from her lunch
because she didn't eat enough he is less
than me and she can't jump we can
rearrange the equation and throw all the
other factors like Alice's mess into a
constant value called K this is a
differential equation and for a spot
outside the well it has a solution
which means that there is a chance for
Alice to get outside of the well this
term contains exponential decay
so the probability gets smaller the
further from the well Alice tries to get
thump down Ellis came and the fall was
over Alice jumped to her feet and looked
up but it was dark overhead in front of
her was a tiny door but she was far too
big and had nowhere to go a table
appeared from the dark and upon it Alice
found a little bottle tied around the
neck of the bottle was a paper label
with the words drink me printed in large
letters after not being able to find a
poisons warning label Alice mentioned to
taste it and finding it to taste very
nice soon finished it off what a curious
feeling said Alice as she shrunk like a
telescope folding up now just the right
size to fit through the door Alice did
just as schrodinger expected and began
to escape the well as she crawled it
became more difficult to move and the
roof got lower and lower but she was
very happy to have tunneled out